and how long you think it'll be until
marijuana action becomes recreational in
Florida I think that by 2020
it'll be voted in there's a there's a
law firm in Tampa right now Michael
minority I'm an RD law he is a huge
advocate he's been working with the
state of Florida for the signatures for
this I actually went over with him one
day and we counted out I think a hundred
and hundred thousand signatures we go
through you have to gonna divide him up
and look at the actual signatures before
that Chiefs have been to the state and
so that's twenty twenty twenty okay I
think though now DeSantis has said
governor DeSantis has said he's not a
big recreational guy us the new governor
in Florida has the new governor in
Florida he's been super super super
receptive on getting this thing rollin
they've got now a finally hired the new
director of cannabis here for the state
of Florida her name is Holly Bell
she came moved here from Kentucky she's
working with Nicki freed who's the new
agriculture commissioner they are
working together to to bring
legalization here to Florida so they're
they're pushing hard on that side I
think when you at the end of the day
when you really look at the tax benefits
that are coming into the state the fact
that this crime rate will also go down
which is a huge benefit yeah look at
what's gonna happen on the just on the
side bringing in new tourism
I mean you figure if we're doing Florida
springing right now about a hundred
million tourists a year that would
probably go to 130 140 yeah real easy
and I mean so the economy would just
boom for that side of it I think that
from our side of it from a hard car side
which is nice we can put vets to work
especially combat that's to come back to
work mm-hmm our business model looks
great and we continue to make that push
to bring these guys in and girls we
actually looked at some females as well
to bring them on great skill sets and to
better help educate everybody with
regards to what's going on with cannabis
here in the state of Florida yeah
there's also that big those big lawyers
out in Orlando the more the Morgans
they're all are they they're pretty big
advocates of well let me tell you
they're huge it's actually quite
interesting we as
we got further involved in this we've
actually had some guys reach out to his
former politicians the former Speaker of
the House John Mills jeff cam caught the
former lieutenant governor obviously
John Morgan looking at when I met with
mr. Morgan figuring out why he was in
this industry was kind of interesting I
said so you have a dog in this fight
right and mr. Morgan actually has a
brother who was paralyzed and once the
30 years ago and realized that the meds
they were giving him we're not really
working the way they had hoped they
would and he realized that moment that
cannabis this is his brother realize
that cannabis seemed to be the best
medication he could get from a pain
reliever perspective a lot of the
medications he was taking were
interfering with his appetite well
obviously we know cannabis is gonna give
you that appetite yeah so it improved
just a quality of life just on from that
aspect of it right and I believe that
mr. Morgan saw that listen if my brother
goes to prison or jail he's not coming
out a better guy so this gave him a
reason to get involved and he would
actually like to see his daughter be the
queen of pot over there in Orlando the
queen of pot I mean a pot that's a nice
ring to it I listen like I say it's uh
it's been an interesting journey to see
the politicians getting involved to hear
the reason why it's the same story over
and over again even with speaking to mr.
Mill's that he had a friend of his just
here recently committed suicide he
believed that he if he had been able to
medicate with cannabis that that would
have happened was that guy it was that
guy uh a combat vet as well absolutely I
was a Vietnam I mean unless we just lost
a colonel over here at the VA in st.
Petersburg about a month and a half ago
yeah it was brains out in the parking
lot sitting on his Awards after 34
amazing years yeah and yeah how does
that happen how does a full-bird colonel
that has you know this great background
all these accommodations awards
beautiful wife you finally retire to
settle in to really enjoy the last part
of your life mmm oh your brains out so
those are the things that we continue to
push against um I've actually found a
group here locally the opticore group
which basically are taking special
operations guys and putting them back to
work
this is the kind of guys we're gonna go
back through and look I bring these guys
into the fold
and obviously from a training
perspective we have all regular training
and again carry firearms we carry a ARS
we have to be certified with us in the
state to carry those especially in an
armored vehicle as well right so well
and you knew a really famous sniper
Chris Kyle right we had we we actually
do a thing down here in Florida